les flèches sokone est repassé était on
les a eus et le poids on n'a pas idée
ils ont entre 16 et 25 ans et pour
certains c'est une première expérience
de travail
l'opération une semaine pour financer
son projet permet à des jeunes
trappistes de travailler pendant cinq
jours soit 25 heures pour un salaire
d'environ 200 euros
le fait de pouvoir présenter des projets
c'est une première approche du monde du
travail donc c'est une manière de se
vendre
en général ils essaient de pouvoir
sortir différentes thématiques qui
sortent un peu de l'ordinaire et puis on
leur demande aussi un cv de façon à ce
que réellement il ya une logique à
savoir cv et motivation qui est vraiment
les premières embauches pas finalement
en partenariat avec la ville et les
bailleurs sociaux ce dispositif réparti
les jeunes sur plusieurs chantiers
cette semaine sensibilisation au tri des
déchets nour a 17 ans et elle avait déjà
participé à un chantier il y a deux ans
cette année elle s'est inscrite pour
financer ces équipements de boxe mon job
en fait c'est d'aller chez les personnes
et de sensibiliser sur le tri on demande
un peu s'ils font du tri si ces enfants
ok s'ils savent un peu parce que
certains nous disent oui oui mais on
pose des petites questions pêche du
genre la bouteille dit il faut la mettre
dans lequel bac le bal jeunes ou vieux
des hommes c'est de savoir un peu parlé
avec eux d'avoir un peu de relations
aussi avec son équipe n'aura va
organiser son après midi en se
répartissant les appartements
vos joueurs ont fait voir si du bayer va
ne savait pas et de la mer et rap ont
fait une action pour la sensibilisation
au tri qu est ce que vous avancez vous
triez vos déchets muni de son flyer la
jeune fille écoute expliqué fourni
prospectus et sacs de tri avant de
continuer sa tournée
ce sac déjà un sévère facilite n'est pas
prendre d'autres sacs quand ils
descendent pour redescendre leurs
poubelles de tout est écrit sur le sec
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre dedans tous
à mettre dans la poubelle jaune et ses
pratiques pour en 2016 sont 120 jeunes
qui participeront à ce programme qui
s'étale sur quatre semaines jusqu'au
mois de mai une réussite puisque depuis
2011 330 jeunes ont pu profiter de ce
dispositif